marries in Syracuse hi meri welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave thank you
so much for taking my call
sure what's up my question is that I am
facing a potential layoff between now
and the end of the year and although my
husband and I I feel have a pretty good
snowball effect going on
I don't know like if I lose my job I've
already done the math like based on
making minimum payments and keeping a
roof over our head we would technically
be in the hole about $700 on just my
husband's income so then I had the
thought that maybe I should take a loan
from my 401k now to pay off some debt
then you know should I get laid off that
was horrible
that's all I do here's why if you leave
you get laid off that loan becomes it's
called due in full instantly if you
don't pay it you're gonna get penalized
and taxes if you've done an early
withdrawal never never never borrow on a
401k no you can't borrow your way out of
that kiddo it doesn't work no I know it
was like paying debt like that's why I
don't think it was a good idea it's a
bad idea double bad idea because Berlin
401k is a bad idea on top of that so
anyway what I would do is this okay we
got storm clouds on the horizon it may
rain is what you're saying and so what
do we do at the point that you think
that it's 50/50 a 50% chance
realistically you're gonna it's a flip
of a coin as to whether you're going to
light off
I would just stop your debt snowball and
pile up cash okay your stall is gonna be
my next idea is we do have about 6,000
in savings right now well you're not
doing it right then what we teach you
what we teach you to do is have 1,000 in
savings how much debt do you have right
I just I just actually came across you
three weeks ago and I'm listening to all
the podcast okay what we teach is baby
step one is one
thousand dollars anything above that
that is not in retirement any kind of
investments or savings above that goes
on your debts in baby step two all of
your debts except your home or baby step
two listed smallest to largest
and attacked in that order minimum
payments on everything but the little
one and in this case five thousand
dollars anything else you can squeeze
out of your budget goes on the little
one
that is if you don't think you're at
fifty-fifty on the work on the work loss
right now is it just a general vague
fear or you think you're 50/50 I don't I
think I got a few months to go know what
I asked I'm asking if there's a 50%
chance at the end of the year you don't
have a job yeah I guess there's a 50%
chance I will be without a job by the
end of the year you're pretty sure
you're not going to have a job I'm
pretty sure because our I work in
finance and everything is going to be
outsourced okay then you need to stop
everything don't don't pay down on your
debt don't take the five thousand out
that I was talking about
don't start the baby steps stop all 401k
investing stop any investing of any kind
and just pile up cash to get ready for
the storm after the storm passes which
means after you get your new job and by
the way I'm looking for that job now if
you're that sure you're gonna lose your
job get a new job okay don't sit around
wait on them to shoot you in the face
you know dodged the bullet right get out
of there they pretty much told you
you're gone so well that's just let's
not be in denial go get a new job and
yeah you know and what so once this
storm has passed and you've got things
stable again then I would walk you up
those baby steps but in the meantime I
want you to have a really nice rainy day
fund a really nice umbrella let's add to
that 6,000 let's get that 6,000 up to
20,000 and in but now if you get a new
job and you get stabilized in that job
then we start and we take any money that
you've saved up and we throw it at those
debts how much debt do you have not
counting your house what we run so we
have a mortgage so it's debt between me
and my husband we hauled together we
have a one hundred and seventy four
thousand dollars in debt 135,000 as his
student loan good lumen payment plan
what does he man what does he do he's a
teacher a teacher for 135,000 he's a
teacher he's got two bachelor's and a
master's and he's been searching like
crazy for trying to get a teaching
position and this year as the first year
he hasn't had to be a substitute teacher
but the school he works for only pays
18,000 a year Xenophon this is a series
of bad choices if you're gonna spend a
hundred thirty-five thousand dollars on
your education you need to go find
something to do to make more than 18
yeah it's an unacceptable career path
given the debt you've got he gave up his
rights to decide to do something that
cheap he'll make some more money than
that can he teach at the at the
collegiate level with his master's he
looked to get into like teaching as a
adjunct teacher at colleges yeah hooters
on the side like he's you know searching
hard is just I don't know what it is
with this area in New York but schools
are not replacing teachers as they
retire well if you're talking about
teaching in high school or below K
through 12 he's got too much education
and too much debt to take that job he's
gonna have to make more than that no I
agree
135 thousand bucks oh my gosh how much
do you guys on your cars has paid off
and I owe three thousand are mine okay
cars aren't your problem then what's
that rest of that debt um we have a
personal loan and we have a couple
credit cards and then I have student
loan debt okay all right cool all right
yeah you're looking for a job he's
looking for a job and you pile up cash
right now stop all investing pile up
cash you have a mess on your hands
and you're right you can't you know you
can't cut through this if you lose this
job so you need to be finding a new job
given that yours is that unstable and of
course he's got to continue to pursue a
career that makes a lot more than
$18,000 a year and if both of you are
looking and there's no teaching
positions in the area that pay more than
18 grand you may need to be looking in a
different town a different area you
maybe didn't need to look at a move to
get your guys out of this mess then you
have a real serious student loan problem
here and you have to address that with
income is the only way to do it
so hey hang on I'm gonna send you a copy
of the book the Total Money Makeover to
help you with this process and you call
me back if I can help you some more okay
this is the Dave Ramsey show